i sort of reject the concept of blunt
honesty
you know you can be honest without being
an ass
um uh you know do i look fat in these
genes
i like the other genes better that's an
honest assessment without making
somebody feel bad uh for example
um and we also have to get good at
evaluating someone's personality
some people are more sensitive than
others and so a good leader
is able to adapt their style and how
they uh
offer information so that um sometimes
they have to be a little more polite to
some and they can be a little more blunt
with another
because their personalities can take it
um
what we want people to do is hear the
feedback hear the input
and it's based on how they receive it
not how we like to give it
we have to be the adaptable ones um as
as
as leaders um but he he's absolutely
right that good leadership starts with
care
and i hear this all the time
unfortunately which is you know as a
leader i didn't get to
i didn't get to choose my team so why
should i care about them or
why should i trust them you know they're
not i didn't choose them well you didn't
get to choose your children
you love them um and this is one of the
the
the the risks of leadership you know
leaders have to take the risk to care
they have to take the risk to trust
first i've never in my life heard a
great leader say prove to me why i
should trust you to their team
it's the opposite a leader takes the
risk to trust and it's the team who says
prove to us why we should trust you
that's the correct hierarchy
um uh so so yes
you don't you do have to care you want
to see you want to see your people as
human beings first
um you know they are not the problem
they may have a problem and inject a
little empathy into the into the
organization this is what
what reflects care uh so for example
i'll give you one one example
um uh so here's a pretty normal scenario
somebody walks into an office and says
you know your numbers are down for the
third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before if
you don't pick up your numbers in the
fourth quarter i don't know what's going
to happen
empathy uh changes that you walk into
their office and you say your numbers
are down for the third quarter in a row
we've had this conversation before are
you okay
what's going on i'm worried about you
that's empathetic that's the expression
of care
that we recognize that someone may have
a problem but they are not the problem